[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting
we're going to be doing a couple of
things one we're going to be exploring a
internet phenomenon that i already know
that most of you are familiar with but
we're going to be breaking it down
um and we're going to be revealing
a secret that i don't think that we've
revealed before about a video that we
made a long time ago we're coming clean
about something dishonest
that we did for a video
and we tend to be honest
we tend to try to be honest i think this
is this is going to be good
yeah uh for to get this off my chest
i ca i can't i mean if it does come up
it pops up in my brain a little shame
i there's a little shame yeah because of
uh because of
uh it's not being discussed not now so
we're gonna bring it out into the open i
will say
just in case we're doing something that
we uh we often do which is we think that
we're saying something for the first
time we actually oh guys like five years
ago you said this on air biscuits
our memories it isn't that our memories
are bad it's that
you essentially have just an open
channel
directly to all our experiences because
we talk about everything that we do
and think and so there's a difference
between remembering something and
remembering if you've talked about it
you know it's like right so we apologize
if we've already come clean about this
and i don't think i'm i mean there are
certain people that
have been a part of my life through the
years who
they've been i forgot they've forgotten
that they've told me this so they're
telling me this in the exact same way
i mean my mom does that a lot now you
know what happens is
you know i was talking to her this
morning she had a um
uh she had her second cataract surgery
and this was the seventh time she told
you about the second cataract surgery
well
she she's told me about five different
times
even though her right eye is there's
something else wrong with it that makes
it hard for her to see out of
they've decided to do the surgery you
know to
to remove the cataract in that eye
anyway because who knows in the future
you know there might be something else
that can fix that problem and then the
cataract will already be removed and you
never know if it will
increase her her
range of vision in that eye anyway and
what i just told you
she has told me for the first time five
times
and it's not i don't i mean maybe isn't
it what she's thinking maybe it's an age
thing but it's like it's the one thing
that when you start talking about well i
had this done to my eye and i'm getting
it done in my other eye
it's just the thing that you talk about
and it's and when you tell
everybody that you talk about well you
know i'm having this procedure done
it's part of it and then i mean i guess
it's a good sign that i've talked to her
enough that i've heard the same thing
five times because i'm you know i've
been talking to her about her eye good
news is
she's got her second she's got the
second eye done and
everything went well we still don't
know because it was yesterday if she's
realizing any of the benefits or who
knows maybe in the future
uh as technology develops you know
there'll be something that can fix the
other problem and then the cataract will
already be removed i don't know if i
said that yeah yeah yeah
i like that that's good that was that
was a nice reference so yeah
how do you correct her do you correct
her when she
you know what so yeah you told me that
yeah the second time i was like yeah you
told me that
third time i don't think i said anything
oh well
i think you got to say it every time
yeah yeah yeah you told me that
well it's just good to what's the update
it's just good to have a comment
the latest you know i think success is
just having a conversation
where she's you know she's processing
and
you know i'm trying i try to ask
questions that will get a different
answer yeah well speaking of old people
with bad memories
uh i was on facebook recently
that's nice um so you and that's
this is a choice because this is not a
habit i mean i'll find myself
on on twitter and i didn't even realize
that it was happening
but that never happens on facebook i do
not go on facebook yeah i have no
i don't have it on my phone um do you
i have it on my phone and the reason
that
uh well i have i've had it on my phone
for years
uh but i do not i'm not a facebook user
yeah it sounds like yeah it's like a
drug well i do not
miss that argument i do not participate
however
uh recently when i was trying to
uh contact people to be a part of
jesse's birthday video
like and i was spanning like family and
friends and like
old friends gotta go to facebook the
only way i could get in touch with some
of her old friends was facebook
so but one of the things that i one of
the reasons that i do
go to facebook at times and i don't know
what this says about me but
uh there's a couple of people that now
first of all
if you go back in time to when we were
first getting on facebook of course we
were individuals on facebook and before
you could have
like a facebook page that was a brand um
the rent link page the mythical page
that we have now
we basically used our personal facebook
pages
for promotional purposes right like back
during the early days like writing the
facebook song
posting that and that kind of thing yeah
and
we in the same way that we were using
twitter
in the early days everybody was using
twitter and facebook
the only point of reference when those
new social media platforms came out at
the time
was myspace and the whole point of
myspace was to have as many friends as
you could possibly have and like you
were ranked by how many friends you had
and so we were like oh of course i'm on
twitter that's why
you followed everybody back on twitter
in fact we both had this thing
installed on twitter where we would
automatically send a message to someone
who followed us and automatically
followed them back
which rendered my twitter that aspect of
my twitter useless
and by the way uh we're hearing this
very
deep vibration somebody's hearing it too
somebody's doing some work
it's like somewhere in the neighborhood
i don't know if you're going to be able
to hear it
lower in the final mix but if you do
hear an occasional
that's what that is it's not one of our
stomachs but we're gonna do our best to
get rid of it
so i went back a couple of years ago and
i
unfollowed a whole lot of people on
twitter because
because of that whole point like
following four or five thousand people
on twitter it's pointless right so i was
like i want to follow people that i'm
actually
not just want to be nice to i want to
hear what they have to say
um and so but where am i going with this
so what that means
is that facebook for me there was like i
think you could have 5 000 friends
as a limit we both got to that place
and then i've just maintained this
facebook account
and when i go on there there's a couple
of people
that i was friends with that i wasn't
really friends with in real
life i think they were in north carolina
that throughout the past four years of
uh the trump presidency seeing what they
say about the situation has these are
friends of friends these are not fans
correct okay that's correct these are
people that i was connected to
in real life in some way seeing
the way they processed the trump
presidency
was just a fascinating sort of like i
felt like it was my
personal tie to a very different
perspective than the perspective that i
have about everything that happened over
the past four years you can dip your toe
in
learn a little something and then no
yeah but i'm not i'm not a facebook
debater i'm not going to get in there
into the comments and do that whole
thing but i go and i see the people
debating
lurk you lurk and so it would that's why
i would go back
well one of the things that i have
noticed
especially this year is ever since
facebook has now done the thing where
they've essentially if you're looking at
facebook on your phone they've adapted
adopted the same
practice that instagram has
and even tick tock where if you click on
the video
uh button on facebook it brings up a
full screen
vertical video that
plays and it plays and then you and the
next one just comes up and plays or you
can swipe and the next one
comes up in place so basically the same
interaction that you have with
those kinds of things so you kind of get
into this loop
and this is not a new phenomenon but
it's something that i sort of
rediscovered and then i was just like i
think we should talk about this on your
biscuits because it brought up some
interesting things for us
and that is the phenomenon
of prank videos on facebook
combined with the requirement for videos
to be
at least three minutes in order to get
monetized
okay now there are has rendered what
a crazy phenomenon it has created this
interesting intersection of people who
are
both making a prank video but also
okay trying to meet the three minute
time limit trying to get to that
three-minute time limit so that they can
monetize it but they're also like
most prank videos if not 99 of prank
videos on the internet are fake
so if you if you take a prank video that
was is fake
and then you require these people who
are not professional actors
and in my estimation don't have a lot of
insight into human behavior in general
like what normal rational human behavior
would be there's a self-exposing
phenomenon
having to meet that time limit exposes
the nature of the thinking and the
acting and the execution
in a way that just it's fascinating so
okay it lays it bare okay and i have a
case study
video i have a case study video that i
kind of want to lead you through and a
couple other ones that i can just talk
to you about but i want to show you one
i find it interesting that
you went on facebook to do some
political lurking yeah but then
this a prank video pops up and then
you just you just found yourself
watching it is what happened
well i i get i don't i'm not proud of
this and
my guess would be that this never
happens to you
um but i will get caught
and just sort of uh i'll just get caught
in a video watching
sort of just binge where i there's
nothing
satisfying at all i feel like it's the
equivalent of being at the slot machine
you're like a
you're like a toddler in front of a
screen it's like oh this color's moving
i'm
i can't my eyes are looking at well it's
just you know i
and i think this happens most often it
is designed this way
of course yeah i would think that this
applies to this is why they made the
interface this way it applies to most
people but like
tick-tock is the perfect example of this
it's just like
you just kind of go into this vegetative
state and just watch a bunch of videos
but
now every other platform is trying to do
the exact same thing yeah
and i fall victim to it and i i dislike
myself when that happens
but at least i discovered something that
i thought would make a good air biscuit
so at least
you know at least we're monetizing it
so you watch this video and you're gonna
okay i can see where this is going but
rhett has not
shown me this video uh and
you i want to see it well you shall
but first um you know what
the new mug that we're selling uh on
good mythical morning
the heat activated mug that that
goes from totally black to just showing
this amazing
vibrant illustration from our good
mythical intro
it has proven very very popular
uh i mean so popular that the last
conversation we had yesterday about it
was that
we were having trouble getting enough
getting enough
made i mean this is great i mean this is
great news that people want the heat
activated mug
but it also illustrates another issue
which is
when we introduce a new mug there is an
old mug that there there's a limited
supply of it and once it's gone
it's gone forever this has become a
collectible my friend
the old gmm mugs are in short supply
if you want to own a piece of history
the the days are fleeting
and there's three there's three colors
we've got two colors right now the
blue slash purple whatever that is the
green and uh
there's an orange as well and they all
have different designs
on them and this is at the last chance
section of the mythical store so
mythical.com go to the last chance
section
and this is essentially things that
there's a limited supply and they're
there and they you can get them now but
when you they're gone they're gone
forever ever forever
unless you want to go buy them for more
on ebay which some people do that
mythical.com last chance section
all right crack open that laptop
and let's go to facebook
okay all right so i can see the title of
this thing right now thief steals bike
and get big karma for the angry face
emoji thief steals biking get big karma
that's grammatically
not correct but i don't forget it i
don't know this matters forget about it
um
and i don't even think is thief spelled
incorrectly
before e except after h yeah
is spelled incorrectly are you sure yeah
i'm really bad at that t-h-i-e-f
is how you spell thief t-h-i-f yeah
you're right yeah yeah so thief is
incorrect steals bike and get big karma
is not that's not grammar okay
again that there's more than just that
that's wrong with this
okay uh so i'm just gonna let i'll let
the beginning unfold and we'll kind of
get into the basic idea
okay
okay let me make sure that the sound is
working because that is that is an
important part of this
all right we're gonna clip this
right there right that's not going
anywhere let me tighten it up okay so
it's a guy so
when they come to steal my bike chaining
a bike to a chain-link fence
he's in a ghillie suit is that what you
call that yeah
oh right there beside the bike yeah so
he's so he's strapping a rope
and the girl film is like you think it's
going to work okay 30 minutes later so
he strapped this bike
to a big rope fence here here comes a
guy running
oh it's oh a bike this is the guy and
he's he looks like a
a fake bush right beside the right side
right beside it it's like he's never
seen a bike before now okay so now he's
sticking out
he's touching the bike he's touching
he's testing the tires out
yeah there's air into tires buddy he
keeps touching the
front tire uh-huh
and this girl filming
okay she's kind of behind he's testing
it just in case you wonder what's
happening the
the tech says he's testing it you want
to make sure
you want to make sure the bike is is
properly inflated and he keeps
he keeps touching the bike let me see
how it rolls
oh he's he's checking the sturdiness of
the body
now okay so and now he's tested but now
he's got to deal with the
existential sort of crisis that he's
having he's got his hands on his
hips and he's walking around no he's
scratching his head and then scratching
his chin like the classic like cartoon
capturing of like inner turmoil yeah
this is
this is the worst it's like he's talking
to himself
yeah he he's dealing with he's thinking
about the consequences of what's
stealing this bike i mean he knows
he's not no no he's thinking about what
a person who would steal a bike but
wouldn't
need to take a long time to do it would
do someone who needs he's looking up at
the sky
and touching he keeps stroking his chin
and looking up at the sky
yeah right okay yeah right this is not
look now he's sought to intelligence now
he's talking to himself look his arms
are out he's like ah
i mean there's no one here
[Laughter]
he's he is he talking to god yeah
oh yeah and this is what is he yeah i
mean he's like doing a soliloquy
here we go here he goes here he goes
hold on there's still a chain
oh and there we go ghillie suit just
strapped it on here we go and look the
way the even starts the bike is a
ridiculous way
i mean the way he okay here we go all
right
don't want to get too fast because i
know that this rope is tied to it
so then and boom oh oh my god so
he did stunt work this stun here we go
listen reset
buddy you okay what happened
what's this on your bike hey man oh it's
like it's like it's not your bike
yeah it's cause it's tied up here's my
bike
so he's chasing look and he also
runs across the bush okay all right all
right so that was
it three minutes 23 seconds of pure
unadulterated prankage
like no totally not fake totally not
acted
let me first just explore a couple of
things because one of the things that
was very fascinating to me
was the comments right because i was
like
well i will say please let the comments
say i'm my intelligence is insulted
any any like a six-year-old
could watch this and pick up on
the non-verbal cues and say this is not
how anyone acts
now i can't tell how many views this has
when i watch it on
my phone i can see i think it was like
over
50 million views i think it was like 80
something million views just to give you
an
idea of how many people have watched
this wow 324 000 people
have reacted to it with a like or a love
or whatever
40 000 people have decided to comment on
it okay
please please restore my faith in
humanity all right
mark says the bike thief is not a good
actor
okay okay even sounds like he's wearing
a microphone a real
thief would have taken the bike in a
second 433 people seem to agree
uh another uh comment here this is all
a lie a thief does not think that much
to steal something
was he so blind that he did not see the
red rope the carabiner
attached to the bike since he inspected
the bike for a long time and finally a
camouflage
net is visible at that distance first of
all as some people have
corrected uh this guy the carabiner was
placed on there
after the fact yeah because the
inspection right as he was about to
take off the bush comes to life and
snaps it on
omg your videos are so annoying because
you think we're all stupid and believe
they're real
ah if you're going to waste all this
time in making them try to make them a
little more believable
is it possible that this lasts more than
three minutes and the guy
with the car was there all the time
watching while the one who takes the
bike
shows that there is no one there is no
logic that's doesn't there's no logic to
that cause
it's an ironic comment okay so
yeah i i actually feel better about that
i mean
the the fact that i don't and i'll tell
you why in a second go ahead
i mean at least the top comments call it
what it is
and and are seen through this thing now
that
none that you read have the insight that
we have as to why this is happening
because of money um but i you know i
i feel i feel better because of this
people are seeing it
but the the system is still rewarding
this this guy's efforts he's got a lot
of paul energy i will also say that
the guy in the ghillie suit paul energy
like paul brothers energy oh
okay just as a side note uh i don't know
if that's a compliment or an insult
to just to the paul to the paul brothers
or to the guy
um here's why i don't feel good about it
because
taking the time to point out something
so
obvious is not something to be proud of
and it's not something to feel good
about yeah yes you're right i would feel
even worse about humanity if there were
people who believed it
and it doesn't seem that anybody really
believes that this
this was a real thing that happened but
it's almost like there's this thing that
they're also implying which is
you know what if this guy was a better
actor i would have appreciated
this video more and that's the thing
that is super interesting to me
is the fact that and this is kind of
what i want to explore
is the idea that this is a genre of
video now first of all the whole fake
prank thing which we'll get to in a
second how that personally applies to us
and what we think about that what the
motivations are for faking a prank
but again when combined with this
uh time length requirement
now i'm going to talk about two other
videos in fact the two the two videos
that came up after this video
that were exactly the same thing just
packaged differently
the first one was um
there was this family that was outside
and they were working on a car and they
had a pair of jeans
okay that they had stuffed with
uh something to make them look like legs
okay and then this guy like a
middle-aged dude like took his shoes off
and put them on the end of these filled
up jeans
and then put the jeans underneath the
car like he was working
on it scarecrow mechanic then he got on
the other side of the car
so that when he talked it sounded like
his voice was coming from underneath the
car
and as soon as they get it set up a
woman comes outside like the mom of the
family or whatever and
at that point it was obvious that it was
fake because
the the timing of the way she there was
no cut no it was just like
okay we're ready and then they just whip
pan and she's like coming out of the
house
and she's like okay i've got the tools
for the car
and then she goes up to the guy
and then he's yelling he's like give me
the wrench and like
she takes the wrench and instead of like
handing it to him she just kind of like
tosses it under the car you know to kind
of play along with the idea that oh i
would believe that he's really under
there first of all
the longer that his fake legs just sit
there not moving at all and are both
right next to each other and the two
feet are kind of like propped to the
side
the more obvious it is that he's not
real and then of course there's a person
in the driver's seat who takes her foot
off of the brake and then it rolls over
the legs and crushes his legs
and then she's going nuts and but the
funny thing is
she doesn't even look back at the fake
leg she gets mad at the woman in the car
it's just again it's a study of human
behavior
that reveals that people don't
understand human behavior
like yeah you know acting acting's not
easy well and now we're not just talking
about writing we're talking about i mean
talking about acting we're talking about
writing right because you got to plan
this a little bit so you know one of the
things that keeps people in a good story
one of the reasons that you like the
movies and the tv shows that you like
is because the way people react to
unbelievable situations is incredibly
believable and relatable
it might not be that it makes a lot of
sense that
people might end up on an island like
they did in lost and not be able to tell
there's unrealistic things that happen
but the people's reactions to the
situation
are believable and relatable and that's
what doesn't happen in any of these
videos
a third video super simple there's a
woman
she and again these videos came up they
were served to me
mister i'm watching fake prank videos on
facebook
with a vengeance they were served up to
me because facebook apparently
understood oh he likes these fake videos
so the next was you you watched all of
the first one
yeah the retention time was full because
i was studying it
you watch the second one and then the
third one comes up and then
there's a woman standing knee deep in a
lake
next to a dock and there is a man behind
her
and he has uh an alligator head
on a fishing line and he puts it in the
water and he's like hey how are the
reservations coming like she's
like she's making reservations on the
phone she's like while standing in water
standing in water facing away from him
okay and of course i don't know who the
person is who's filming this interaction
and why she's not paying attention to
them
let's not think about that and she says
oh yeah it's taking a second
and then he's like well you uh you know
you need to be watchful when you're in
the water because there's all kinds of
stuff in in
lakes like sea snakes she literally said
that
alligators and she's like alligators
alligators are my number one fear and
you know that
but she's not turning around to see him
so he has to maintain again to get to
the three-minute limit
which i didn't even talk about the the
the way they stalled that mechanic video
is she kept handing him tools
oh my gosh it just took for
they have to pick the moment in which
they stall the video to keep you
watching to get to that three minute
mark
in the gator video it's literally just
the husband moving the gator around
behind her
and continuing the conversation like how
are the reservations coming
for three minutes and then eventually do
you still not like gators
she sees the gator and freaks out
whatever so i
i believe we've said this but it bears
saying again
you don't get paid by facebook for your
videos
unless they break the three-minute mark
yeah
it's it's created a prank monster
but it's well it's exp you'd think it
would expose pranks
that's the point that's what's hard i
think that's the underlying point
is that facebook doesn't care about this
because they get they make money and
apparently the people making the videos
don't care it's it's not
like well they're not they take it as a
personal insult that you find it fake
they just go and make the next one
it's they have embraced my theory is
that the people who are making these
videos
have embraced the fact that of course
it's fake
you know i'm doing my best to make you
believe that it's fake and maybe there's
a
certain small sliver of the population
that's not that smart
uh that does believe that this is real
but we're kind of
all agreeing with the fact that yeah
this is fake it's not that big of a deal
but you watched it and i made money so
i'm going to make the next one and and
if people dislike the video enough i
mean that the algorith
these algorithms do take that into
account but the you know the the main
thing is
if people are going to watch a whole
video there's no denying
the fact that it it kept people on the
platform
and it takes a lot to override that and
they're not gonna out
they're not gonna program the algorithm
to outweigh
likes to dislikes or ratio or however
they look at that
to whether you watched or not you know
it's it's the principle of
um with netflix it's a it's a different
thing but it's a similar principle
that uh netflix just started
showing you recommended things that you
think you'd like to watch
and leaning on that instead of the queue
when netflix first came around
it was all about the queue it was all
about
i want to watch this next this next this
next and you would just go through it
but there was
the discovery mechanisms were you know
they had a they had a long way to
develop
and they since have so now netflix is
mostly about that as are all of these
streaming services
and by the way that's why youtube
subscriptions have been buried
for years right but for this principle
that like
it's not what you your stated intention
it's your it's your actual actions
that are the telltale signs of what
what's gonna work
and then what what we can sell the most
against and this is actually
uh this illustrates i'm gonna i'm gonna
make a political
or uh i guess you could call it a
political point at this point
um because this is an example
of why when profit
is the primary motive behind a process
it doesn't i mean i grew up you know
conservative
guy who thought that this idea of the
free market
and the fact that everybody being
motivated by money
will ultimately bring out the best
possible outcome right like a pure
capitalistic view
i've since competition makes everything
better i've since
uh recalibrated that view and i'm not
well versed on these issues but just
there's so many examples in modern
society of how profit being the goal
causes things to first of all it causes
a lot of people to suffer
i'm not saying anybody's suffering in
this situation necessarily
but you know we speaking of facebook and
all social media in general
we've seen that this whole idea of
keeping people on the platform
and keeping people watching ads has led
to this incredible political
polarization in our country as
was very well explored in the this was
the social dilemma documentary on
netflix
but this is just an example of profit
being the motivation leading to a
very bad product this is like this
hasn't led to a great
pride this has led to something that
truly sucks
in every sense of the word fake prank
videos
that are fake prank videos suck period
yeah fake prank videos that are drawn
out for three minutes in order to make a
profit for the person who has decided to
make a living in this way
are awesome suck squared which makes it
kind of awesome
and so i might get back on facebook so
i'm just making the point
that it that isn't the case i think that
what makes the human collective better
and is beneficial to all of us
is a better motivator than profit but
again off the off the soapbox as a
as a side note our i mean arguably our
entire career
and success post good mythical morning
or during and well we're still doing
good mythical morning but you know post
the launch of a mythical morning
is based on this algorithmic phenomenon
of watch time as well
you know yeah but we benefit from that
we didn't know that
you know we wanted to have a
conversation we formatted a show we we
we made something that we were proud of
and our our team is is committed to
excellence and
doing the best we can and so very
quickly we arrived at
to have a a meaningful conversation
you were you were at the 12 minute mark
but we were actually cautioned
to not go far beyond the 10 minute mark
but then
youtube changed you know from
emphasizing subscriptions to
watch time and rewarding that so
you know we made the best product which
you know started
getting broke 10 minutes got closer to
15 minutes
and people stuck around and they watched
the whole thing
and so we were rewarded because we
rewarded
the viewer and they just kept binge
watching we had so many of the episodes
that
uh everybody won in that situation
well as an example of the the content
being motivated by
the system and the in the in the profit
but uh making a product that
fits within that system that hasn't
compromised itself
for the sake of that of the profit we
didn't
we didn't know about the principle when
we were formatting good mythical morning
but right um now as we're
you know as we're reformatting good
mythical morning and creating cuts
for facebook right or making
new sketches that we put on instagram we
absolutely have to take into account
at what's the threshold to be able to
monetize i mean
you know we can't just make videos and
and not be able
to and then the platform refused to run
ads against them
so facebook you know that three minute
mark means a lot to us too
so yeah if you're watching on facebook
and by the way that's how my mom watches
good mythical morning so every time i
talk to her another thing she'll say
she's like
yeah i've been watching more of your
show uh lately
and she'll talk about a video and i'll
be like well that that's two years ago
that video is like four years old mom
she's like i was like you need to look
at our hairstyles to really figure it
out
because the way that facebook will serve
it up
is it it's seemingly random yeah
it's you know once you watch an old one
and maybe
sometimes we repost stuff right um but
the main thing we're doing is we make
uh cuts of good mythical morning cut
downs we call it
that break the three-minute mark but
that work within the facebook
environment but again they break the
three-minute mark
well because they're 12 15-minute
episodes and that's easy
it's actually it's an easy thing to cut
it down it's something that we're proud
of the place that we kind of relate to
this a little bit
is instagram yeah igtv there's
monetization there as well it's
you know it's in its infancy and it's
not that significant
but the the threat the threshold for
monetization on instagram is
two minutes so the way that we
try to address that is not by taking a
concept that
i think the thing that all these videos
these prank videos that i just talked
about
especially the alligator one and the
bike thief one
you could tell this story in a much more
compelling way in about
30 seconds 30 seconds right yeah um
now we create sketches that
from the the conceptualization and the
writing and the execution of the
sketches
is like okay is this a concept that
makes sense in two in two minutes we
don't stretch anything out
um so yes we are playing this game
because we're not
and this is this is a business and so
we're not going to
take the time to dress up and be
characters and make this video
just for kicks it's part of that we're
like oh if we can make this thing two
minutes long we can actually get paid to
do it okay
so let's make it two minutes long but we
have artistic
pride you know somewhere so i mean
yeah yeah that is questionable sometimes
no we do we
we don't we do we are this is something
that we've always been
i've always felt dirty yeah
about the system and even i mean i think
the best example of this
is the titling and thumbnailing of
youtube videos
which is a whole conversation that we
can have but just to quickly cover it
you know the reason that the our
thumbnails on youtube look the way that
they do
is not because we think that they look
good i mean just to be frank with you
like i do not like to see
me making faces
that close up i don't i don't like it i
i hate i hate it like i'm pretty close
to you right now
if this is this is like like
i mean i don't even have to extend my
arm all the way to poke your eye out
that's how close i am sitting to you and
this is the approximation of how close
if like if you were recreating the
thumbnail experience in real life
yeah and i think right you know
psychologically if you're making look at
me
look at me and do it yeah if you're if
you're this close to me making faces
like that
you want to slap me and you're about to
eat something you want to slap
don't yeah why would you make eye
contact with me
while eating at this close of a range
much less
yeah when making that face you're making
so i want to
like that's not i want to slap me human
man every time i see
one of our gmm thumbnails i want to slap
me or you whoever is featured
and i am assuming a lot so people feel
the same way but you know what
three i got a thumbs up something down
they should add a slap through
doing this for a decade and fine-tuning
that which
slaves to that what we have determined
is that that style of thumbnail
and there's a lot of different factors
that go into that style of thumbnail
working
is what gets us the most views
right and so yeah do you like you said
we've got artistic integrity but we are
we do play the game we are willing to
compromise we do a b testing on
both titles and thumbnails every single
morning it's like hey this one's not
really
catching uh we think we need to change
this word to this that's why if you
watch
from the very beginning every day you'll
see some changes because hey this is a
game we're trying to play we're trying
to win and we're playing within the
system
we personally are not involved in that
because i just
cannot even talking about it it's
demoralizing
but the the one thing that we that we
couldn't do is make that prank video
i just couldn't i just i just you know
we so we've checked
some pride at the door but we try to
maintain some integrity though because
while i do want to slap you when i see
you in a thumbnail and also myself so it
goes both ways
um what i'm doing in the thumbnail what
you're doing in the thumbnail
is not misleading it it is indicative of
what they're going to see in the video
and the title is
also indicative there may be sometimes
it's a little sensational
maybe a little bit of a misleading thing
but
as a principle it is supposed to be
indicative because we understand that
there's a long-term relationship that we
have with our audience and if we begin
to mislead the audience and take you as
a bunch of fools
you're not going to stick around for
very long right and that's the other
thing that's insulting
so we have a history with prank videos
you know as creators as artistes
um and we you know we just couldn't bear
to keep it up now i will say one
you know one of our one of our first
videos
uh is trimming strangers nose hairs at
the mall
now this was made before youtube existed
because we were making videos
um we were you know when we were
involved in crew and we were
we were hosting the uh or emceeing the
the regional christmas conference we'd
make comedy videos we talked about this
in the lost years
and that's where this video came from
from the i think it was the
greensboro the greensboro mall
because it was the the christmas
conference was in greensboro and
you know it's just one of the hey we
need to make a video we made we made
sketches
we were we were writing songs but we
would also do prank videos
it was just a genre that you did but we
really did it we really took a nose
trimmer
to the mall and wore these
i mean you can look it up on the renton
link youtube channel and watch it but
um i think i'm pretty sure it's still
public it shouldn't be
it's horrible but the thing that's not
horrible that the redemptive
value is that you can tell that we
really went up to strangers
and trimmed their nose hairs people
would you know you could talk people
into doing that
right i mean and there's we it's implied
that we're just going around the mall
doing this so i'm about to trim your
nose hairs and i've just trimmed
who knows how many other people's nose
hairs were the same device it was
heinous
yeah but it never crossed our minds that
we would fake it
it was just because that's the that's
the beauty of it the beauty of it was
getting the real reaction
people yeah and that's what we were into
the fact that we really did it
one i mean it for me whenever we come up
with something like that i'm like
this is go time we've got to show that
we got to bought the balls to do this
and to your credit you're right there
with me but
there was a lot more inner turmoil with
you than there was with me i could just
switch
off my conscience yeah i don't like
people this i have to
i have to make this work i would say i
would say that
because i have to you know we've got a
we've got to make a funny video we've
got to do this
it's not it's not just that it's not
that you have a stronger commitment to
making a funny video i think that i
think
i think it's that you are much more
comfortable
in life in general than making people
uncomfortable so i'm
i i don't i and i don't know what this
says about me but like
i can't i have a real difficult time
making people
feel uncomfortable that's why i do the
sympathetic laughing you know like
if you watch when we have guests and
people point this out like when we have
guests when we used to have guests on
gmm
before covered we will have them again
um
i'll laugh at everything they say
because there's this and again
there's it's called i think it's called
just called sympathetic laughing and
it's basically
you laugh to subtly communicate that
you're not a threat and trying to make
the person feel comfortable
right now i find myself doing that i
find it interesting
in this conversation you're the one
who's a little more on the defensive
than me
but i i'm basically the one who is like
me
in these videos much more the willing
jackass like i i i watch that stuff back
and i don't want to be that person
anymore it starts to eat away
at who you are if you know because i'm i
guess i so i've kind of switched
but but for the sake of these kinds of
videos it's better to be that way though
sure so but my point is that was one of
the factors that took us away from doing
prank videos
the other one was
yeah because it it it just starts to
make it starts to make both of us feel
icky inside i think to take advantage of
people
i think my theory is that it was a
cultural change
that took place um not not that prank
videos are not still a thing
but there's a generational change and
especially when
right all the other content that you
make is generally
nice nice and good-hearted like you know
we try to uplift
people we're not our comedy is not
cynical
the observations that we try to make
about people are not demoralizing or
derogatory in general
so then but we still have this really
like we're fascinated with people and we
do both enjoy putting people into
uncomfortable situations
and that's what our local commercials
were in a lot of ways right look we were
walking this line
yeah but screwing with people at the
dirt track race like with a fake
survey like remember that video it's a
lot harder for me it's much easier for
me
you're lying to people you try to right
you can laugh at them
but like but but it's a it's a much
finer line with the local commercials
because we're doing something that
is like this is going to benefit your
business and we're also
collaborating this is an idea that you
either came up with or you bought into
but we're going to stand here and get
you to say this line knowing that it's
going to be funny for reasons that you
may not
fully understand i'm much more
comfortable with that but when i have to
like be
literally interacting with somebody on
camera and it's just harder for me to do
there's a cultural shift but at the same
time there's not
these videos are still going like tens
of millions of views on facebook
they're all fake they're not all fake
i mean you and you look at the success
of the impractical jokers now that's an
older audience
that's not like this i think it's
generation it's a savvy feeling
i think sorry for people i mean my kids
i love my kids love impractical jokes
and i think criminals
i've never done i've never watched it
but i think that they
they make themselves the butt of the
joke a lot of the time
they're making they're primarily trying
to embarrass
one another as friends and they and if
it's much more about that
they never leave but then even if they
make somebody feel bad
they let them in on the joke at the end
i think they don't
they may do that in real life like the
big
but they don't do that it's not like
candy camera always ended like the old
candy camera
show always ended with hey man i'm just
joking there's a hidden camera there's a
hidden camera
they don't do that on practical jokers
they may do that off camera but they
don't make that part of the bit it's
just not a part of it
i think what the last prank video we
made
just just broke our spirit and we were
like never again will we do this
uh and so now if we haven't done it
before there's a confession to make i
feel like we need to make
the confession upfront because it'll
make watching the video and
that and make an analysis of it that
much more insightful
this video is called invisible dog prank
released
on our rhett link channel it's about to
break 2 million views
it was released february 26 2013
and there are elements of this video
that were faked now this
this video was a i don't know how sorry
i am yet we need to talk it through
this video was sponsored and uh
there were these new headphones from uh
was it dts gts
yeah dts had these new headphones called
x technology it was 3d like surround
sound
and so we were going to go to their
headquarters which was out
west of here and the idea was let's make
a video
where to demonstrate how realistic this
3d
sound is we're going to make people
think that there
is a dog about to attack them from
behind
while they're doing i don't even know
what we told them we were going to do
we'll figure that out in the video well
let's
you will watch the video together but um
yeah i remember why we constructed this
concept
and then sold it to dts but we can talk
about that afterwards so let's just it's
a three minute 42
second video so hey it could go on
facebook it's 42 seconds longer than it
needs to be all right
this is bullet he's actually a pretty
nice dog but he's been trained to do
this
i'm gonna make people think they're
being attacked by them but it'll just be
in their headphones
here's the setup dts has developed a
technology that creates a realistic 3d
like surround sound experience through
just a pair of headphones but our test
subjects don't know that they think
they're just coming in for a hearing
test and a focus group
yeah and this is at their studio at the
dts so we were
we were playing uh dts employees that's
why we had the uh
the shirts on yeah
scary dog in the middle of our lame test
we introduced the surround sound of
bullet attacking them from behind
but when they turn around there's no dog
it's just a grumpy looking cat
named perfect so first of all we got we
we also got
uh is that gruffy cat no it's a grumpy
cat lookalike
may he rest in peace did grumpy cat
perfect was grumpy cat a thing is that
oh yeah
so so we didn't come up with grumpy cat
i don't
want to give us that much credit but
it's like you think it's a dog then you
turn around and see a cat
this is this is a fun fun fun prank
however here's what happened on the day
uh now the funny thing is not on the day
in planning
on planning we were like we this video
has to work
yeah so we need some insurance that if
we don't get
reactions that are you know shareable
and buzzworthy we have to have a plan b
to ensure that
so you know we were adamant that we were
going to conduct the prank
legitimately now i don't know if i'm
just as memoralizing in my own head but
that is not how i remember it
what i remember i know that's what we
did and then what we would do i need to
as we watch it i might be able to pick
out people but i think what we did was
we would get people to which kind of
people do it twice we got people to do
it again
we got him legitimately the first time
yep and then if it wasn't good enough we
said hey let's do that we're going to do
that again now you know what's going to
happen
and just really like when you hear the
dog bark just really react like you're
scared and we were like
hopefully enough of these people will
react in a way that's believable
and we'll pepper those things in but
there was a hope
even while i was there yeah there was a
hope that we wouldn't have to use any of
that stuff
we wouldn't have to resort it was an
insurance policy to direct it to anybody
yeah so
the only difference in my mind is that
we came up with that on the day when we
saw that people weren't
reacting great as opposed to we playing
it like weeks ahead of time that's the
only thing i remember differently
is that we were like they're not
reacting that great let's just well
let's just get them to do it again and
maybe we'll use it
it felt like we were really easing into
it and i will say this is totally
on us because no one who works for us
now not even stevie worked for us when
we made this video
yes she did she had just started this is
february uh
2013 uh and
i think we hired her bef between filming
this and editing this
so she wasn't there during the or
between getting the job and filming it
yeah yeah yeah so it was like one of the
first things that she was involved with
but she may have just been involved with
it i don't know if she was there that
day she may just been involved with the
edit but
but she wasn't making she wasn't part of
these type of decisions that we were
making out of the time because it's like
we
were very adamant that we i'm sure we
were
that we wanted to we wanted to do the
best we could to actually scare people
oh yeah and then we just had a plan
because
pranks existed at the time all right so
let's watch it and we can
see if i can pick out the places where
uh it's
it's fake maybe that first one this girl
right here says oh my god i think that
was fake
what's your name edward okay so we got
the first guy coming in
we're gonna do a little audio test today
and the dog is
why is there a dog in the studio you
know there's dogs in studio we were
trying to
cue that okay there is a dog here that
might attack you so he was afraid of the
dog right then
because the dog starts barking whenever
you walk through the door
yeah all right just put those on
okay and make that comfortable let's do
it
hello thank you for participating in the
dts audio preliminary sound now this guy
i love watching these they're obviously
real people right
they're not they don't come across as
actors in any way but this guy is an
actor
this guy was on workaholics really okay
and multiple things it's a one minute
mark because here's what happens and
people and this is this is interesting
phenomenon with prank videos in general
and i think people talk about this in
the in the comments
in la when you put a call out for people
to come be a part of
any type of any kind of focus group you
get people who
also are actors and extras yeah so it's
just because it's a los angeles and
that's what a lot of people do and so it
makes it seem like we hired actors
because this guy and at least a few
other people
are actors audio preliminary sound
perception test
we will begin by testing your hearing
fidelity in each ear if you hear a tone
in your left ear raise your left hand
if you hear it in your right ear raise
your right they're very serious
the guy with the mustache it at a a
minute and 10 seconds
he's in something yeah a tim and eric
thing i think
for this next portion of the test we
will be testing your audio visual
location perception
you will hear a tone and its perceived
location will move from side to side
see we're really getting received
location of the tone with really getting
on
let's see there's jason yeah jason was
still working for us then
they're following his eyes here comes
the cat in a basket
it doesn't look like a real cat but it
is
see she knows this is silly thank you
for this next portion of the test we
will measure your
range perception you will hear a series
of tones varying in volume and pitch
and you will be asked to give specific
responses to a series of questions oh my
god
i'm sorry okay was that real
i don't know so good though it was she
was so good yeah i don't know
all right this guy that was real
that was totally real that guy shaking
was real man in this next portion of the
test we will measure your frequency
range perception you will hear a series
of tones this guy's chill
there's no way he's going to react
oh we did the old slow-mo replay
all right pause it now that guy threw
the chair fake
i don't remember i gotta say i'm i
i remember telling him because he was so
chill he didn't respond we were like now
like you said you see what's up now
we were playing a joke on you can you do
it again
and again because it's not it's not that
we were getting actors but all these
people who respond to all these
focus group things are actors so it
actually played into their psyche
to get direction to do something again
they all took it so he yeah and i
remember seeing
i mean maybe you throw the chair
maybe you throw the chair just put a
little idea
it feels so dirty now man
this is the guy from tim and eric
remember we saw the german shepherd when
i came in
oh yeah
oh my god why would y'all do that to me
so here we are laughing at it that was
fake
robot really
that seemed real if you thought a dog
was technology yeah attacking
you that was a robot cat and the guy was
like really
it's like a real cat technology yeah you
did a prank on a prank
yeah are you serious what's the most
scared you've ever been in your life
prior today
my hands are shaking when my girl's
pregnancy test came out pregnant
and she's like 60. oh we should hang out
yeah you're cool man i might have peed a
little but i'm all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right so first of all there was no
mean sponsored like well because there
was no sponsor language at the end
because we
here's the thing we were we were at a
desperate point you know we were we were
trying to scrap
together a living we had we'd start a
good mythical morning but like
we weren't making money off of it really
so it was
i'm just saying we were a bit desperate
to feed our families don't hold this
against us
but you know the final product that we
created
was not icky it actually it actually had
a good
feeling but which one is worse so good
right from a moral perspective
no i just let's just really explore this
which one is worse
one that most intelligent people believe
was real but was
fake or ones that the person who makes
the video
is already dealt with the fact that they
make prank videos and they get con
fake prank videos and they constantly
get accused of it but they just keep
making the videos and there's a bit of a
knowingness between them and the
audience that this is all fake but
you're still watching it
which one's more morally wrong i just
i know which one's the worst video the
ones that
the whole knowing this thing i just
don't think that's legitimate across the
board
i agree i'm not playing devil's advocate
so i don't think this is
this is a fair question because i mean i
never talked to roman atwood
about his switch you know he he really
made a name for himself with his prank
videos pranking his own family and
i think other people too um but then he
totally switched it to just like a
family vlogger promoted positivity
and then he totally stopped making
videos
i don't know why he made he did he's not
making videos at all
he made like a couple in the past year i
mean talk about a guy you know talk
about running the
the youtube gauntlet like starting out
with prank videos
and then trying to figure out what makes
people angry when they watch it
like i mean you know there's people who
it's just mean-spirited taking advantage
of people
there's lots of lots of stuff done in
poor taste and i'm not talking about
roman atwood i'm just talking about
prank videos
but he was you know a guy like him in
that world like we sidestepped that
world we just dabbled in it with this
one video really once we were once we
had
yeah a sizeable audience but then he
jumps over to
family vlogging which is a you know
another
death gauntlet of of personal yeah
personal health where you end up
basically i don't know his story but
that's my observation
but you end up applying the same
principles if if you're doing family
vlogging and you're good at it
yeah you're you're making a reality show
and everybody knows that reality shows
are fake
and so the situation i'm not saying that
and i'm i'm sure that that line gets
super confusing and super grey of like
okay well let's set this up like this
it's kind of actually happening but we
need to do it this way for the camera
like
that kind of stuff happens but it could
eat away at your soul
but the prank thing is just seedy i mean
i love ed bassmaster like i've always
been a fan of his he's still around
but he uh but his pranks were always
real we used him in a video and as well
you know and
i can i consider him a friend like if i
saw him now i'd i would just be elated
to give to god
and the way that i enjoy ed's videos at
this point
is through instagram i follow him on
instagram
and his videos come up and it's like
snippets
from what he does on youtube and you
know he's
he's still doing it and it's still funny
it's still funny but the but the
heart and soul of it is his
characterization
and getting people's response to him
and not just it's not first
first about putting people in
compromised positions where it's like
it feels icky well i mean i think he'll
go there but there's an example
that you're familiar with because i'm
familiar with it and
i don't know how much i don't think
there's much crossover between our
audience and their audience
um but because i have a teenage son i
know about
nelk n-e-l-k rhymes with belk
and these guys um it's a group of guys
from
canada and their videos are so uh
full sinned i would i would call them
full they're the full send guys that
full send brand is their
their deal and um their videos are so
uh let's just say uh distasteful
according to the youtube uh ad system
that they they can't monetize
any of their content but they have long
since accepted the fact that over the
edge
they're not going to uh they're not
going to worry about that they make
their money through i guess brand deals
and merch and that kind of like they
would prank
cops by drinking non-alcoholic
beer while driving vehicles and getting
pulled over
and then like baiting cops to pull them
over so that feels icky
now first of all i'm gonna go ahead and
tell you that it's not hidden camera
stuff it's like doc style
if you consider yourself a retin-link
fan and you're into
the concept of mythicality and you
your general disposition in the world is
to like make people's
lives better and to be nice to people
you might even be offended by the fact
that we're even talking about these guys
they took they went out on a big front
hunt but then they put
one of the guys in a bit in a obviously
fake
bigfoot costume and then
baited this guy yeah i mean i think to
the point where
i i i think their main joke was that
he was gonna have sex with uh bigfoot
well one of them
was you know
basically taken advantage of by bigfoot
and then he comes back
so first of all let me let me just be
very clear again it i feel like we have
to
we we need to do this it's that i'm not
endorsing
these guys i know we're talking about
them and some people will go watch them
they've got plenty of views they don't
need our help
um uh they are offensive they will
if you are offended by
basically any way that you can be
offended you will be offended by these
guys so that is my warning to you don't
go watch them if you
if if watching people make jokes that
make fun
of all kinds of uh
groups i don't watch stuff i only watch
the video you showed me this is on you
but i will say
i don't and i and listen i've only i i
say i've watched
four of their videos in in my lifetime
so i'm not
i'm just i'm just putting a disclaimer
out there that you're going to get
offended you're probably offended that
i'm even talking about them if you know
what they do just i feel like i have to
say that
i'm i'm i'm grateful that we're not in a
place where we feel like we have to
justify ourselves to do
more prank videos where we're like
mitigating our risk by
rigging it and feeling icky inside and
then saying we're not going we're never
going to say anything about this to
anybody right because that was a cut
it's a conversation that we had it's
like everybody who's involved now
you can't say it that we rigged this
because
you know that's going to erode any trust
that people have in us across the board
it's good though it's all on the table
at this point would we do it
you know do we regret doing that making
that video
i think so i mean i do but it's also it
was 2013
like you said it was extenuating
circumstances we didn't end up making a
habit of it
we knew that it was a one-time thing and
we actually made
a sort of an unspoken decision at that
point to be like let's not ever do a
prank video again because
we understand the forces at play when
you make a video and you're like i want
it to be a great video and if you really
want it to be a great video
you'll end up faking things in order to
make it a great video
if you're us so it's like we can't try
to keep ourselves from that
and we know we're not willing to push
people as far as like
nelk would push people to get the real
crazy reactions so it kind of just puts
you in a no man's land where
you either do something that's going to
be offensive to a large portion of the
population
or you do something like from a true
offense standpoint
or you're going to do something that's
artistically so bad that it's offensive
so we just are like we're not going to
do either of those things let's just
stay out of that world all together and
make content that
you know is uh mostly wholesome
mostly wholesome mythical
i think we can leave it to that i don't
know if i feel any better
but at least it's out there hey we trust
you to do with that information what you
will and maybe that doesn't include
uh unsubscribing yeah unsubscribe
and i will just say for those of you who
are going to be offended at me for
giving a very lukewarm endorsement
of milk um after you go and watch their
videos don't go watch their videos i'm
not giving
i'm saying don't go watch their videos
yeah okay
how about that how's that for an
endorsement uh i also have a wreck
so let's do that so um it's an elk right
it's not an elk it's something called
meat church meat church that sounds even
more problematic this is a guy named uh
matt pittman
who's uh i follow his instagram meat
church
uh he's i think he's he's down in texas
he's maybe austin or outside of austin
and a lot of people have asked me where
did you get the recipe give me the
recipe for
um your nashville hot chicken
well i just got it from i got it from
meat church you just click on the
like their link tree link in the
instagram profile and it brings up all
the recipes it also takes you to the
store
where he sells all kinds of like rubs
and there's a rub that's used there's a
there's a dredge that's used in that
process and the recipe
this is also where i got the recipe for
uh how i did green bean casserole how
i've done some ribs and brisket and that
kind of thing he's basically he's got a
youtube channel
anyway that's where i got the recipe
from if you're into uh
smoking barbecuing meats i'm getting
hungry right now
check out meat church and i rec and i do
recommend all the products because
you can go to certain places and get
recipes for your own rubs which i kind
of i respect the
make your own rub game but it's easier
to just buy your own rub
so that's what i find to be uh more
convenient and he's got some good rubs
meet church yeah on instagram yeah i
mean i think it's also just a website
just if you search meat church it'll
come up
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
you think about this join the
conversation and as always
follow us on twitter at mythical
and heck follow us on facebook too if
you want to get some
some good mythical cut downs but on
twitter
we put out questions that we then
discuss on this show if you want to be a
part of it and get a shout out
follow us at mythical and hashtag your
biscuits
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]